[Applaudissements]
en juin 2005 un événement inattendu est
venu bouleverser ma vie à tel point que
je me souviens de chaque détail de cette
journée à cette époque avec ma mère et
mes frères et soeurs nous habitions au
pré-saint-gervais une petite commune
située en seine saint denis
j'avais 15 ans j'étais jeune insouciant
et j'adorais m'amuser j'ai passé des
heures et des heures à jouer dehors avec
mes amis mais ce jour là je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'ai décidé de rester à la
maison
j'étais assis à regarder tranquillement
la télé et là d'un coup j'entends
d'ailleurs le monde terrible je me suis
tout de suite crispé je me suis
longuement approché par ma porte
d'entrée plus j'approchais plus les
hurlements était puissant je pris mon
courage à deux mains
j'ai ouvert cette porte est ce que je
vis c'était littéralement l'enfer un
incendie venait de se déclarer dans mon
immeuble je sentais une chaleur
insoutenable
je voyais les flammes au loin qui venait
vers moi j'ai décidé de courir vers mon
balcon pour échapper à la fumée mais
rien à faire elle était beaucoup trop
épaisse j'étais accroché à la rambarde
et je devais prendre une décision pour
sauver ma peau j'ai décidé de sauter bah
oui je vais pas précisé mais j'habite au
7e étage il était accroché à la rambarde
je paniquais mais bizarrement mon esprit
était très clair et à ce moment là j'ai
eu un déclic ont l'instinct de survie
repris le dessus et je me suis dit que
j'étais pas prêt à mourir alors je suis
passé de l'autre côté de la barrière
je me suis longuement laisser glisser je
me suis balancé de toutes mes forces
vers l'étagé en dessous
j'y suis arrivé de justesse j'avais
l'épaule disloquée mais j'étais vivant à
ce moment là je ne me doutais pas que
son malheureux événement est léchée pas
les changer littéralement toute ma vie
et qu'à cause de cela
j'allais livrer le combat le plus
difficile que l'on puisse en faisait un
enfant la survie
ma famille n'a pas été relogées
immédiatement sous prétexte que nous
étions en situation irrégulière notre
office de chez l'homme on a profité pour
nous mettre dehors
ma mère et mes petits frères seront dus
à la l'hôtel pour ma part c'était
différent
j'ai pris une autre décision j'ai décidé
de me débrouiller seul
c'était principalement pour éviter à ma
mère de s'endetter et c'était surtout
pour la soulager
c'était une décision très difficile car
ça m'a amené dans la rue j'étais devenu
sdf
vous savez quand on est sdf c'est encore
plus horrible que ce que vous pouvez
imaginer
en général quand nous avons une activité
de prévu nous allons d'un point a vers
un point b et on ne prête pas forcément
attention à tout ce qui se passe autour
de nous car nous savons pertinemment que
nous n'allons pas reporter arpenter
éternellement ses rues mais quand on est
sdf c'est différent on a un sens du
détail exceptionnelle auprès absolument
attention à tout car le moindre
changement de l'environnement peut nous
être fatal alors dit comme ça ça peut
paraître un peu exagéré mais je vais
vous donner un exemple admettons qu en
face de chez vous il ya un abribus et
qu'à côté de cet abri bus il y ait des
travaux et qu'à cause de ces mêmes
travaux cet abribus va être détruit
jusque là tout va bien rien de neuf mais
en fait si ça l'est parce que vous ne
savez pas c'est que tous les soirs à cet
abri de bus asd venus trouver refuge
c'était un point de repère ça lui
permettait de se ressourcer de se
protéger des intempéries
vous imaginez sa surprise et son chagrin
quand ils arrivent sur les lieux et
qu'il découvre que cet abribus n'est
plus là pour moi c'était ça la rue un
univers difficile et impitoyable un
univers que j'avais rapidement envie de
quitter un univers qui m'a fait
découvrir la peur et la solitude
mon plus grand rêve sur le moment était
de m'échapper de cette prison et
découvrir de nouveaux horizons
vous savez contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait croire ce qui m'a le plus
manqué ce n'était pas un toit ou même de
la nourriture
c'était de la chaleur humaine car je me
sentais terriblement seul et en colère
je voyais des milliers de personnes
passaient chaque jour devant moi sans
pouvoir échanger avec aucune d'entre
elles et pourtant j'avais énormément de
choses à dire mais personne pour
m'écouter
je sentais que j'étais clairement en
train de perdre une part de moi même qui
me semblait pourtant bien acquise on
humanité je devais réagir
ça devenait vital je devais trouver une
solution mais comment faire j'étais seul
j'étais sdf
j'avais 16 ans et j'étais surtout très
en colère alors je me suis posé la
question et je me suis demandé ce qui au
plus profond de moi même me manquer et à
ce moment là j'ai eu un déclic c'est
évident c'était la parole je vous assure
qu'à ce moment là j'étais persuadé qu'on
prenant la parole
j'allais littéralement pouvoir changer
tous les événements de ma vie alors j'ai
commencé par une toute petite action
tous les matins toutes les personnes que
j'ai croisés dans la rue et je les ai
salués alors au départ je ne vais pas
vous mentir au médecin en avait beaucoup
mais petit à petit certaines personnes
me répondait et de fil en aiguille
certaines d'entre elles même sympathisé
avec moi ils me racontaient leurs peines
leurs joies leurs quotidiens et c'était
pareil pour moi je pouvais enfin de
livrer à d'autres personnes je me
sentais revivre je sentais que je
redevenais un être humain
simplement parce que j'ai décidé de
reprendre la parole et c'est d'ailleurs
grâce à cela que j'ai repris contact
avec ma famille car c'est une passante
que j'ai salué tous les matins qui m'a
dirigé vers une assistante sociale qui
elle même m'a dirigé vers ma famille
c'est formidable histoire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes tous capables d'effectuer ce
genre de petites actions et je reste
persuadé que nous nous devons de le
faire car en prenant la parole pour y
lutter contre la solitude améliorer son
quotidien et celui des autres nous
pourrions arrêter de ne percevoir comme
des étrangers et faire un pas vers
l'autre
après ce malheureux événement j'étais à
la fac à l'université de paris 8 à saint
denis
un ami m'a parlé d'un concours
d'éloquence le concours et le cancer
c'est un concours d'éloquence qui promet
la prise de parole en public alors au
départ quand il m'en a parlé je me suis
dit non ce n'était pas un exercice qui
était fait pour moi prendre la parole
devant un amphithéâtre bondé compris
entre 800 et 1000 personnes c'est tout
c'est pas pareil mais j'ai perçu ça
comme une opportunité je me suis dit que
c'était l'occasion que j'attendais
l'occasion pouvoir m'exprimer à nouveau
l'occasion du mec de pouvoir m'exprimer
devant un public d'être entendus et
cette fois ci à une échelle beaucoup
plus grande
c'était une aventure formidable
nous avons eu la chance l'année de notre
de notre promotion d'avoir un
documentaire un film qui a été tourné
sur notre sur cette promo qui se nomme à
voix haute
il est actuellement au cinéma je vous
invite à aller le voir car pour moi
c'est un véritable bol d'air frais et en
vérité un véritable hymne à la liberté
d'expression
vous imaginez je suis passé du silence à
l'expression publique et cette fois-ci
ma parole était entendu à une échelle
nationale tout ça parce que j'ai
simplement décidé de la reprendre
après tout ça je me sentais obligé de
poursuivre cette aventure de continuer à
transmettre et véhiculer ce message car
je sentais enfin que je commençais à
m'évader de cette prison et qu'il était
temps pour moi de découvrir de nouveaux
horizons
j'ai pris mon envol j'ai pris le large
je me suis dirigé vers mon continent
d'origine l'afrique
aujourd'hui je fais du développement
durable en afrique de l'ouest en guinée
plus précisément avec mon père et un ami
nous avons des projets agricoles et des
projets éducatifs nous voulons redonner
la parole aux plus démunis qu'ils nous
racontent leur peine les problèmes
qu'elles rencontrent
et comment est ce que nous pouvons faire
pour résoudre ses problèmes grâce à ça
la première idée qui nous est venue
c'est de créer une école alors pourquoi
une école car pour moi les enfants sont
les meilleurs ambassadeurs de la prise
de parole car qui mieux qu'un enfant
peut transmettre dans le futur ce
message de paix d'amour et de tolérance
très souvent je reçois beaucoup de
messages de ces mêmes enfants et de
leurs et de leur famille également
il me remercie et sont très heureux de
ce que nous avons accompli laborde
mais ce qu'ils ne savent pas c'est que
c'est moi qui ai leur sueur et de vol
c'est moi qui les remercie
pourquoi car à travers eux ils me perds
il me permet de continuer à prendre la
parole et vous savez notre école en
slogans et c'est celui ci est canidés
mois ce qui signifie ne restent pas
silencieux et prend la parole
[Applaudissements]